♪ [upbeat music plays]
Anthony Romano: So Eureka Streams.
It's built on GWT on the front end,
Java on the back end.
And what it does is it,
similar to Twitter and Facebook,
it provides social networking tools,
but for an internal company.
Everything's kept on their internal LAN.
Companies can download it and use it
and communicate across teams,
special interest groups,
ethics, Go Green initiatives.
Executives can use it to give
accolades or give kudos.
We have some executives
who have thousands,
a couple thousand followers
in the system.
So right now, we get about
10,000 people a day,
unique people a day using
this system, 45, 000 page views.
So, it gets a lot of use.
Five hundred groups.
These range from, as I mentioned,
special interest groups.
We have product groups.
We have functional management groups.
We have support groups.
We've actually shut down
multiple help desk centers
to be replaced by support streams
that can be manned by one person
instead of three people.
Rob Keane: We decided
to use Google Web Toolkit
because on a couple of
past projects for our team,
we had had some trouble maintaining
large code bases of JavaScript.
And we knew that we wanted to code
the back end of the project in Java.
So, Google Web Toolkit
was kind of a natural choice
because it allowed us to use Java
on both the front end and the back end
and gave us a lot of the advantages
that would be really hard to hand code.
Like, the GWT compiler does
a lot of the optimization for you.
You don't really need to worry
about that nearly as much as you do
when you're writing your own JavaScript.
Anthony Romano: GWT gets us a lot
of things for free--history management,
we have eventing, handlers.
All of these things we have for free now
that the developers doesn't have to
reinvent the wheel with JavaScript
and try to manage the history themselves
or download a dozen JavaScript libraries
to get what GWT gets us
for free out of the box.
Rob Keane: For Eureka Streams,
next we're basically gonna
be focusing on mobile.
We're gonna be developing
some native apps
in addition to first class email support.
Anthony Romano: We have several
success stories on Eureka
where individuals from different teams
collaborated, came together,
solved problems,
saved probably thousands and thousands
of dollars of the company's time
by coming together and
they never would have met before.
And so, if we demonstrate this,
if we go to executives and say,
"This is why transparency is good,
because it allows teams,
people to communicate across these
stove pipe boundaries that you've set up."
And we can kind of crash
and destroy those barriers
and let people communicate freely.
I think that would be
the path going forward.
00:02:26.583,00:00:00.000